[Musique]
et pour en parler avec nous david
rigoulet roze de chercheur spécialiste
du moyen-orient rattaché à l'institut
français d'analysé stratégique l'ifas
monsieur rigoulet roze bienvenu merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
d'alors donald trump a écrit sur twitter
après 19 ans il est temps pour eux de
faire à la police dans leur propre pays
certes mais est ce que les afghans en
ont les moyens actuellement je crois que
c'est pas la préoccupation du président
donald trump et ce depuis les
négociations à marche forcée avec les
talibans qui ont débouché sur l'accord
du 9 février dernier il y avait
l'obsession du président c'est
effectivement rapatrier les boys
donc c'est pas une nouveauté en soi on
peut pas dire qu'il ya une accélération
alors l'accélération à une telle crise
tissier par une mesures opportunes enfin
le facteur opportun à savoir le kobe qui
qui accélère le retrait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les retraites en avance sur
le calendrier puisque normalement
c'était à il devait y avoir un 8600
l'effectif à la mi juillet on serait
déjà à moins de 7500 soldats
justement en termes de retrait donc
c'est une accélération effectivement qui
est amplifié par un contexte général
mais qui rentre tout à fait dans le
calendrier dans les impératifs du
président donald trump
d'autant plus qu'il ya la perspective de
la présidentielle justement en novembre
et que compte tenu de la situation
interne aux états unis c'est un élément
évidemment important pour l'affichage de
présidentielle alors contre le retrait
des troupes américaines un lait
talibans se sont engagées à négocier
avec kaboul on année où concrètement de
ses négociations avec le pouvoir afghan
alors il ya eu effectivement un moment
de flottement parce que dans le cadre de
l'accord qui a été signé avec notamment
une clause qui prévoyait la libération
de plusieurs milliers de taliban 5000 en
l'occurrence d'un côté et puis de
l'élargissement de d'un millier de
prisonniers des forces gouvernementales
et donc ça faisait l'objet d'un blocage
parce que le gouvernement n'avait pas
été consultée en la matière et donc
c'est ça alimente effectivement le les
retards dans des négociations putative
intra afghane qui est la deuxième phase
normalement attendu plus dans le cadre
de l'accord signé alors les choses se
sont plutôt améliorée récemment puisque
il ya 2 jours 9 sont détenus talibans
ont été relâchés et que sans une
centaine avaient été déjà la veille et
que des sources talibanes évoque la
possibilité pour leur part de relâcher
également de ce 200 membres des forces
gouvernementales qui serait sous leur
contrôle
donc il ya un manifestement
effectivement un effort de part et
d'autre pour que les obstacles soient
levés
même s'ils sont en effet pas du tout
présager un dénouement favorable sur
d'éventuelles négociations entre taliban
d'un côté et gouvernants d'autant plus
que le gouvernement a été divisé
évidemment dans le résidentiel entre les
deux ashraf ghani et puis là-bas et que
il a fallu une pression très forte des
états unis vous retrouvez un compromis
susceptible de présenter une
une posture une île vis-à-vis des
talibans
alors messieurs a rigolé vous justement
cet accord entre ashraf ghani et
abdullah abdullah ce qu'on peut parler
dans l'accord fragile et pas vraiment
durable will est fragile et il reprend
une certaine manière ce qui avait été
fait lors de la précédente
présidentielle
l'accord a été a été effectivement plus
ou moins acté à savoir qu' on
permettrait d'autres
auprès abadla de choisir une partie des
gouverneurs des provinces notamment dans
le nord du pays
et puis une répartition des rôles mais
qui est relativement instable
effectivement est qui qui tient beaucoup
à la pression économique des etats-unis
puisque mike pomper l'eau et a fait un
déplacement express le 23 mars dernier
où il a fait passer un message très
clair notamment sur le milliard de
dollars qui pourraient être suspendus si
un compromis entre les deux parties
n'étaient pas trouvé d'autant plus que
ce cet argent évidemment est considéré
comme vital par le gouvernement
donc on voit bien qu'il ya la pression
américaine qui est de toute façon par
rapport au retrait que les etats unis
soient taxés accéléré monsieur rigoler
rose merci d'abord et en direct avec son
je rappelle que vous êtes un chercheur
spécialiste du moyen-orient est rattaché
à l'institut français d'analysé
stratégique merci